oh
it's ricky big bsf bullet calf podcast
place two on the way look far as
rap [ __ ] go i cannot have no sympathy
for him the gun in a guitar case i play
a little symphony for him
my [ __ ] put the work in i'ma go get
some tiffany for
proof of every purchase is exactly what
business is full
[ __ ] ain't conductors pluto feel
duchess blowing out train smoke
all i do is chain smoke my son saw me
crying i told him this how the game go
nice see me shining i told him just let
your change grow your escrow is that
bankroll
my net worth need a safe code i shoot
you out the game just like jr where they
say so
have you under pressure like you playing
for the lake show cause shots come right
after the news just like the late show
protected by the blood i got angels all
around me my shooter take the iron off
it's hit like robert downey
i got money for the bail i got money for
the bounty
same [ __ ] to the world same [ __ ] in
the county it was money all around me
[ __ ] getting to it all suspicious [ __ ]
it i guess i might try it audition
now it's really 62's driver hit the
partition cause the best years i had was
in buffalo troy vincent
my [ __ ] like curling ray breaks i like
koi fishes that shows we ain't that far
apart but sure at some distance i'm just
a henna god fisher
with a little slum village before i wait
on you i'll pilfer if i'm starving i'm a
pillage
quarter mill to get the deal close it's
half with the incentives 100 000 off of
verses without merchants or no gimmicks
[ __ ] fake as a columbia appointment
with the dentist i should break another
record like i'm going for the guinness
[ __ ] okay the work came from harford
like the white freinie
blue vet running through the red lights
easy i ain't italian but i like cd
diamonds on me water just like fiji now
i'm at the top easy
always available to block newton i was a
hugger like a female at church i'm
eating first
[ __ ] front and put his face on a shirt
[ __ ] just merch when my [ __ ] pull up
shooting pace puke and she get a purse
check the synopsis my brother eat with
me finesses
but i got the ring on like i'm conscious
well fed portobello mushroom with the
lobster
white wine tastes better with the pasta
we really monsters
oh my [ __ ] goodness man
yo man i told them people check their
synopsis my brother eat with me
tenacious
but i got the ring on like i'm conscious
[ __ ]
[ __ ] these [ __ ] talking about big
ricky hi [ __ ] place two on the way
best album in the world i guarantee it
[Music]
look welcome to the ball fest the rapper
on our test stashing her arm rest for
these stacks in my off sweats
she pulled up in the crosstalk just to
let me get her all wet i had a lot of
things but [ __ ] something i ain't
bought yet leah's shoes right at the
doorstep three closets and i still ain't
seen them all yet
deposits coming like the faucet i ain't
seen them all yet
drawback after drawback wolverine i had
to claw back never thought that all my
pain that they award that cause then
used to call back
texts left red made me fall back only
getting richer help me solve that to the
game i had to charge that
god bless it was all bad tears i fought
back stuck to the format yeah
cause me and them we ain't no sore the
same i owned my masses way before i went
and bought a chain
i see level at the level like some sort
of game they gon think travis just
dropped cause it's all the flames
jersey's still on my body [ __ ] is still
on my body it's all in vain i'ma spin em
like the baggage claim
ever since that baggage came they
couldn't act the same money always
prevail who ain't used to having things
it's cool
i learned quick but made changes quicker
going figure i'm the captain now like my
name is skipper she was trying to choose
me
truth be told i wouldn't pick her cause
she gonna choose another when i'm gone
to november
we ain't stuntin on ig's or socials at
all if we
post it is ours motivation for y'all
been getting hotter though i should be
getting closer to god i pray at night to
keep me strong and they don't do me no
harm
[Music]
moss